tengo muchas ganas de resolver esta
desigualdad fíjate bien esa desigualdad
cuadrática menos x que multiplica a 2x
menos 14 esto esto es más grande o igual
más grande o igual que 24 que 24 y tengo
muchas ganas de resolver esta esta
expresión que tengo aquí esta
desigualdad porque se ve bastante
interesante pero creo que voy a esperar
un poco a que tú intente resolverlo
primero y después veas si llegamos al
mismo resultado así que bastante un poco
en lo que vimos en el vídeo pasado y te
recomiendo que vas a llegar a un punto
en donde tienes que pensar sobre lo que
estás diciendo la desigualdad así que
intenta lo que ahorita les seguimos con
este vídeo
muy bien vamos a intentar resolver esta
desigualdad que tengo aquí así que lo
primero que se me ocurre es multiplicar
esta x por este 2x están menos x por
este 2x y están menos x por este menos
14 y vamos a llegar aquí tenemos a menos
2 x cuadrada ok menos por más es menos y
menos por menos es más más 14 x ok esto
va a ser más grande o igual que 24 pero
de una vez voy a pasar este 24 del otro
lado de la desigualdad así que para
pasarlo del otro lado voy a restar 24 de
ambos lados de la desigualdad recuerda
que cuando tú sumas o restas algo en una
desigualdad la desigualdad se conserva
por lo tanto esto lo voy a pasar para
acá y no va a quedar menos 24 que estoy
restando 24 ambos lados la desigualdad
esto va a ser mayor o igual que es 0 de
lujo aquí tengo mi desigualdad
cuadrática ahora yo prefiero simplificar
un poco los términos porque todo es
divisible entre 2 de hecho todo es
divisible entre menos así que vamos a
quitar este signo de aquí vamos a
dividir todo entre menos 2 para que sea
mucho más fácil factorizar yo en lo
personal prefiero hacer esto a
factorizar esta expresión que tengo aquí
así que dividamos todo entre menos 2
ahora antes de hacerlo quiero que
recuerdes algo muy importante para
nosotros dividimos o multiplicamos una
desigualdad por un valor negativo la
desigualdad se voltean es decir que
ahorita que dividamos todo entre menos 2
esta desigualdad se va a voltear en
lugar de quedarme mayor o igual me va a
quedar menor o igual que cero así que
vamos a hacerlo vamos a dividir todo
entre -2 y no va a quedar menos 2 entre
menos 2 es uno por equis cuadrada nos va
a quedar es cuadrada ok
14 entre menos 2 me da menos 7 recuerda
que menos 2 es un valor negativo
entonces me va a quedar menos 7 x lo
único que hice fue más pues entre menos
menos 14 entre 12 7 aquí tengo menos 24
pero lo voy a dividir entre menos 2 por
lo tanto menos entre menos me da más 24
entre 2012 y justo aquí es lo más
importante vamos a voltear la
desigualdad porque estoy dividiendo toda
la desigualdad toda la desigualdad por
menos 2 lo que haga de un lado la
desigualdad lo voy a hacer del otro pero
como menos 2 es un número negativo
entonces aquí me va a quedar 0 y la
desigualdad se voltea se cambia ok y
ahora que tengo esta expresión aquí creo
que es mucho más fácil factorizar la
fíjate bien estoy buscando dos números
cuya multiplicación cuyo producto sea 12
y cuya suman o restan sea menos 7 ahora
lo que quiero que veas es que 12 es un
número positivo y menos ciento su número
negativo por lo tanto tienen que ser dos
valores negativos porque si yo tomarán
dos valores positivos la suma nunca me
va a dar un número negativo por lo tanto
me voy a fijar en dos números negativos
cuyo producto sea 2 y bueno 6 por 2 6
por 2 12 no no son esos 12 por 1
3 x 4 claro 3 x 4 si yo me tomo menos 3
y menos 4 date cuenta que cuando los
multiplico menos x menos me da más 3 por
4 es 12 y cuando lo sumo menos 3 menos 4
me da menos 7 y está de lujo porque
ahora sí puedo decir que esta expresión
va a quedar de la siguiente manera esto
es lo mismo que x menos 3 ok es uno de
los valores que obtuve el factorizar ok
esto que a su vez multiplica a x menos 4
a x menos 4 ok y esto también nos puede
factorizar y esto tiene que ser menor o
igual que es 0 de lujo ahora justo aquí
es donde yo te decía que reflexionar es
un poco sobre lo que dice la desigualdad
fíjate bien la desigualdad me dice que
un número que multiplica a otro número
un valor que multiplica trobador me da
algo menor o igual que 0 por lo tanto
algo negativo y si yo tengo un valor un
número que multiplica a otro número a
otro valor que me dé algo negativo
forzosamente o el primero es positivo el
segundo negativo o al revés el primero
es negativo y el segundo es positivo no
queda de otra para que obtenga algo
negativo algún menor o igual que cero o
puede ser también cero o pueden ser cero
estás de acuerdo ok pero para que me dé
algo menor o igual que cero no queda de
otra o uno de 220 o en su dado caso
deben de tener cinco nuevos contrarios
uno debe ser positivo y el otro es
negativo así que pensemos que el primero
para empezar va a ser positivo y por lo
tanto el segundo déjame cambiar de color
el segundo va a ser negativo ok entonces
vamos a ponerlo así
en el primer caso me voy a tomar a x 3 y
lo voy a poner con nuestro color x menos
3 que sea un número positivo o 0 es
decir mayor o igual que 0 ok ya tenemos
número que puedes hacer es un número
positivo y a su vez y a su vez me puede
tomar que x menos 4 y de gm tome el
mismo color que x menos 4 sea un número
menor o igual a 0 pueden ser 0 pero
también puede ser menor que cero y
recuerda que cuando tengo algo positivo
por algo negativo me da algo negativo ya
está aquí vamos bien bueno ya sea que
pase esto ya sea que pase esto o en su
dado caso pase lo contrario y le voy a
poner con este mismo color
o pasó lo contrario y que es que pase lo
contrario bueno que x menos 3 sea un
número menor o igual que 0 lo voy a
poner con este color x menos 3 sea un
número menor o igual que 0
y también que al mismo tiempo pase que x
menos 4 sea un número mayor o igual que
0 que x menos 4 sea un número mayor o
igual que es 0 es las dos opciones y no
queda de otra o el primero es mayor o
igual que 0 y el segundo menor o igual
que 0 para obtener algún menor o igual
que 0 o en su dado caso el primero es
menor o igual que 0 el primero es
negativo o 0 y el segundo forzosamente
tiene que ser mayor o igual que 0 de
lujo así que vamos a verificar qué es lo
que me dicen estas dos expresiones vamos
a trabajarlas por separado en la primera
siguió despejó de aquí a equis voy a
obtener que x debe de ser mayor o igual
que 3 lo único que estoy haciendo
sumando 3 b ambos lados de esta
desigualdad que x sea mayor o igual que
3 y a su vez ya su vez también que pase
que x sea que x sea menor o igual que 4
ok estoy buscando los números los
valores para x que sean más grandes que
3 y que sean menores o iguales que 4 y
cuáles son estas bueno pues si te fijas
son las equis que están entre 3 y 4 es
más lo podremos escribir de la siguiente
manera son todas las equis que sean más
grandes o iguales que tres más grandes o
iguales que tres ya su vez sean más
pequeñas o iguales que cuatro más
pequeñas o iguales que cuatro dicho de
otra manera de las equis que están entre
3 y 4 tocando al 3 y tocando al 4 ok
bueno esto por una parte ahora vamos a
fijarnos que me dice estas dos
desigualdades de la derecha yo lo que
quiero en este caso es que x sea menor o
igual que 3 ok lo único que hice fue
sumar tres de ambos lados de esta
desigualdad y a su vez que x sea más
grande o igual x sea más grande o igual
que 4 y en este momento no es decir oye
sal pero esto no tiene nada de sentido
yo no tengo ninguna equis que sea menor
o igual que 3 ya su vez que sea mayor o
igual que 4 no existe ninguna de ellas
por lo tanto este caso es vacío no
existen
de solución si yo me fijo en este par de
desigualdades no hay ningún número
ningún valor para x que cumpla que sea a
su vez más pequeño o igual que 3 y y a
su vez que sea más grande o igual que 4
no existe ninguna por lo tanto este caso
no es posible su solución es vacío o no
existe x que satisfagan estas dos
igualdades
simultáneamente recuerda que cuando
tengo el i tienen que pasar que estén en
ambas aquí igual como tengo el lead
estoy buscando las x que sean más
grandes o iguales que 3 y a su vez que
sean más pequeñas o iguales que 4 y son
estas aquí y de hecho ya tengo mi
solución mi solución solamente son estas
x que son más grandes o iguales que 3 y
más chicas o iguales que 4 es decir esto
de aquí esto de aquí es mi solución de
esta desigualdad de esta desigualdad con
la que empezamos y ahora lo podemos
visualizar en una recta numérica vamos a
dibujar aquí me dicta numérica imagínate
que este es mi eje x
dejando aquí este es mi eje x ok y si
por aquí tenemos al cero por aquí
tenemos al cero ahora imagínate que aquí
tengo el 1 al 2 al 3 y al 4 este es el
valor de 3 ok este es el valor de 4 y mi
conjunto solución las x que satisfacen
esta desigualdad son las que están entre
3 y 4 así que me voy a fijar en las x
que son más grandes que tres es decir
voy a poner aquí un circulito lo voy a
rellenar porque si toca el 3 aquí tengo
una desigualdad menor o igual y no voy a
fijar en las más grandes de tres las más
grandes de tres ok pero que a su vez
sean más pequeñas que cuatro así que le
paro por aquí y me voy a fijar en las
que son más pequeñas que cuatro este si
lo toca porque es una desigualdad menor
o igual y las más pequeñas que cuatro ok
todas estas son mi conjunto solución las
que están entre 3 y 4 y bueno ahora
quiero que te des cuenta de lo siguiente
este de aquí es mi conjunto solución de
esta desigualdad cuadrática con la que
empecé ahora quiero que te des cuenta
muy padre si yo me tomo esta parte de
aquí y le igualó ayer o me fijo en ella
como una función si te das cuenta esta
parte de aquí sin contar la desigualdad
solamente esta parte de aquí es una
parábola y es una parábola que se ve más
o menos así es una parábola que abre
hacia abajo y que corta al eje de las x
precisamente en el valor de 3 en el
valor de 4 se vería más o menos así una
parábola que va a ir más o menos por
aquí y va a pasar por este punto después
va a bajar va a cruzar por aquí y va a
pasar por este otro punto ahora date
cuenta que aquí lo que estoy buscando
son las equis que hay en esta función
más grande o igual que cero y si
nosotros nos damos cuenta que aquí está
el eje leyes si este es el eje valles ok
más o menos se ve así entonces los
valores para ye que son positivos que
son más grandes uruguayos que 0 son
entre estos valores de 34 fíjate que son
todos estos de aquí estos son los
posibles valores que dan a esta función
un valor positivo ahora tú me puedes
decir que lo podemos ver también con la
otra parábola es decir gente que todo
esto todo esto ya demográficas en esta
de aquí me voy a fijar en esta expresión
que tengo aquí en esta expresión que
tengo aquí de igual manera si me fijo en
el lado izquierdo y lo pienso esto como
una función te vas a dar cuenta que es
una función que representa una parábola
pero en esta ocasión es una parábola que
abre hacia arriba porque tenemos el
término que está al lado de la ex
cuadrada positivo por lo tanto se vería
más o menos así cruzaría aligerarse aquí
está en un valor de 13 4 y se vería más
o menos así sería una parábola que
pasaría por aquí que pasaría por acá y
se abre más o menos así ahora quiero que
te des cuenta que esta parábola lo que
me está diciendo esta desigualdad de kim
es que quiero que la función sea menor o
igual que 0 si estás el eje de la y es
porque estoy buscando es las 10 que
satisfagan que sean menores o iguales
que 0 y si te das cuenta en esta
parábola las únicas 10 que son menores
iguales que 0 son curiosamente las que
están entre 3 y 4 vuestros buscando las
menores o iguales que 0 y son todos x
que estén entre 3 y 4 que hacen que esta
función sea negativa de lujo no